keep visualizer is a visualization tool
that helps you analyze the excess
patterns in your cloud BigTable instance
the cloud BigTable console lets you
monitor your application with line
charts which is effective in most cases
however how would you know what is
causing high CPU if there are any
hotspots or large rows or if a MapReduce
is affecting your serving latency that's
why we are announcing key visualizer for
cloud BigTable it shows you read and
write patterns in two dimensions over
time and across key space it helps you
find or prevent hotspots it helps you
find rows with too much data which can
cause performance issues and you can see
if your key schema is balanced key
visualizer has a heat map that shows
time horizontally in this example we see
the number of operations over one week
the key space is shown vertically a heat
scale shows values of a selected metric
for example opps from cold representing
zero over blue to purple to red to
yellow to glowing white for very high
values the tooltip will show us details
about this metric for particular time
and key range in this example notice
that some key ranges like the one at the
bottom exhibit a diurnal pattern whereas
other ranges are very cold
also notice the white glowing line in
the middle that shows the busiest key
range the diagonal lines represent
linear scans possibly from a MapReduce
job the bar chart at the bottom shows
average values across all visible keys
in 15-minute intervals
similarly the bar chart on the right
shows the averages over time per key
range this peak again shows our busiest
key BigTable developers often create
keys with a prefix hierarchy in this
example we see keys that are constructed
with DES limiters such as slashes or
dashes key visualizer has a heuristic
that automatically extracts the prefix
tree from your key schema if available
the key prefix hierarchy is shown on the
left side we can see that the behavior
of a table often correlates with the key
prefixes as in this example when we
click on a prefix it will zoom into the
corresponding key range we can also zoom
and pan by using the scroll wheel or
dragging key visualizer offers you these
11 metrics UPS is the sum of read and
write operations the three warning
metrics read or write pressure index and
large rows can discover problem areas
then we have read metrics right metrics
latency and the amount of data stored
key visualizer
automatically analyzes the performance
of your BigTable instance this may
involve trillions of metric values not
only does key visualizer aggregate all
these metric values to visualize them in
the browser it also performs a detailed
analysis on your tables performance this
produces the following metrics read
pressure which is an opaque function of
Reed CPU read queue length which is the
number of read ops waiting to be
executed and latency write pressure is a
similar function to detect bad
performance for writing and larger as'
which will flag any row that contains
more than one gigabyte of data the
result shown in this view lets us
discover and prevent hotspots best of
all these computations won't cause any
performance degradation on your table
and all this is free let's now see how
we made this easy for you key visualizer
opens by default with the ops metric
this gives us an overview of the
activity in your table then you check if
there are any warnings at the top bar if
there aren't that's good news your
tables performance is most likely fine
this example has three warnings one of
them is severe as indicated by the three
exclamation marks
clicking on the read pressure index
warning brings us to the read pressure
metric where we see immediately where
and when the problem happened
we now zoom into the white glowing
stripe the tooltip shows us which keys
are causing problems at the top we see
the worst problem it's a single key that
has been stressed for more than three
hours we can see the precise name of the
offending key we can see that it was
using nearly 600 million nodes worth of
CPU which is more than half a server CPU
and it tells us what caused this bad
performance this row contains nine point
twenty two gigabytes of data which is
way more than the recommended 256
megabytes per row in all these examples
we were looking at one metric at a time
very often however we want to compare
different metrics rather than switching
between metrics we can show all the
metrics and their values together on the
right when we expand these we can see
all these metrics and miniature views
the zoom and pan operations are
synchronized so we could compare details
for each metric key visualizer for cloud
BigTable visualizes the key access
patterns in your table helps you find
hotspots and large rows it extracts the
key prefix hierarchy if available key
visualizer analyzes trillions of metric
values to point you to problem areas and
it does this without any impact on your
cloud BigTable performance
[Music]